bonsoir ça va aller mieux que le texte
chers amis chers amis monsieur mini la
culture antoine jamel debbouze c'est
ultra honoré que j'ai accepté ce soir de
remettre le costume du meilleur césar à
quelqu'un qui compte pour moi beaucoup
pour la seconde fois je me rejoins votre
invitation à cette grande messe du
cinéma que sont les césar cette année
encore nous avons un parterre flamboyant
total en jupe thyssen n'at-il pas dit
le cinéma c'est l'opéra du 20e siècle on
a tous les arts pour faire une belle
oeuvre des écrivains des acteurs des
chefs opérateurs et les musiciens à moi
de rajouter les costumes
le costume appelé aussi tenu
est un ensemble de vêtements et
d'accessoires assortis afin d'être
portés ensemble
il peut être composer librement ou
imposer c'est le cas des vêtements
professionnels
quand je dis les vêtements
professionnels j'entends par là les
costumes de chantier les pendants citic
il peut aussi être un déguisement ou à
cause du cinéma ou de théâtre comme le
costume d'arlequin
le prompteur il est un peu limite
j'essaie de rattraper mais
ce peut être un vêtement strictement
professionnel comme le costume
d'audience que sont les robes de
magistrat ou encore je passe dans l'eau
ou le costume d'amiante un ouvrier
fondeurs du simple panne décoré aux
parures impérial le costume est souvent
porteur de sens et de symboles donc oui
oui le président demande si vous
pourriez faire un petit peu plus bref
s'il vous plaît trop long ah ouais bah
oui jamais lui c'est un sa petite femme
aussi à mon avis hein
quand celle où aucun c'est trop long
quand c'est pas marrant on l'a vu ton
speech au début un
tu sais moi là dans mac os des mois ce
qu'elle a dit qu'elle avait raison
jamais c'est toujours la même chose
monsieur le président me demande si
possible de ne pas lui parler
directement vous adressez à moi
un trop long
bah ouais mais vient
vient jamais un bien petit monsieur
bonsoir
macaq
françois tessier président président
s'il vous plaît c'est ça qui poulet qui
viennent le président un homme toujours
président de sa présidence il est élu
par qui le président et ben par le
peuple à l'unanimité président élu
président il a vu tous les filles
oui la gueule juge utile oui j'ai dû
pratiquer oui tous elle a vu camille
redouble george lucas mureaux 2 r2
pourquoi commis evian jusqu'à la malle
travail à l'école en utilisant son site
naturel des meilleures ventes urbains et
les adieux à la reine mais déjà vu le
président luiz est le président du jury
les adieux à la reine évidemment et
c'est qui la reine c'est siav sa femme
du roi c'est catherine de médicis qui au
début était pas d'accord que ce qui se
disait à laval à voile à dire tu sais
que je mène tu fais honte au cinéma
français
son père et sa mère et son frère et
soeur mais non oui
derrière
o'neill famille unie et c'est à lui
qu'on adorait être m costiou je suis
désolé président t'aurais pu remettre à
costil la bible comme un espadon lane
amy tu sais jamais le costume que je
pour ce soir c'est exactement le même
que jean dujardin avait au jt de là où
ça se passait ah oui à des grands et des
petits
mais tu sais pourquoi irais pas là jean
dujardin parce qu'il a los angeles
oui un autre chose parce qu'il est né un
jour férié c'est pas possible
les personnes jean notât naissance un
hôpital
tu vois pas le rapport
telle la chance que je suis président
j'ai pas le droit de me battre c'est
dans les statuts mais dégage aussi ça
aussi c'est vrai statut
allez tu me laisses déterminer les voies
alors
je m'excuse quand j'ai dit tout à
l'heure macaques parce que mois déjà
mais c'est quelqu'un que j'apprécie
énormément le japon jamais jamais
l'homme j'aime le comédien le le côté
leaders d'opinion le président à dire
merci françois on peut considérer que la
querelle et l'idée fausse que moi moi là
bas je suis pas quelqu'un de
foncièrement raciste je suis d'accord
françois j'ai rien contre l'aj d'accord
moi je m'en offrant chaînon soubelet
parce qu'on s'est quand même pris une
petite dizaine de minutes dans la vue là
merci donc jeu dans la foulée
les nominés
parce qu'aussi ramette le les nominés
des costumes c'est quand même pas non
plus le oui d'accord car le référé à m
l'acteur ou la grande taille des classes
sous le sable ça ne retire en rien le
respect que j'ai pour les costumes
en général la retenue